PROSTITUTE.
I'M NOT GOING FARTHER THAN THAT.
>> Sean: YOU CAN GO AS FAR AS
YOU WANT.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
AT THE BEGINNING OF WHAT IS
POISED TO BE ANOTHER AWFUL WEEK
FOR YOUR PRESIDENT, JOE BIDEN.
WHEN YOU THINK IT COULDN'T GET
ANY WORSE, THINK AGAIN.
ECONOMISTS ARE WARNING THAT
TOMORROW'S INFLATION REPORT IS
LIKELY TO BE VERY UGLY.
PRICES CONTINUE TO RISE, NO END
IN SIGHT.
WE WILL GET THE OFFICIAL NUMBERS
TOMORROW.
EXPERTS NOW FEAR IT COULD BE AS
HIGH AS 8.4%.
THAT WILL BE A NUMBER WE HAVE
NOT SEEN SINCE 1981.
SO THE QUESTION TONIGHT IS, HOW
IS JEN PSAKI AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION GOING TO EXPLAIN
THIS OUT-OF-CONTROL INFLATION.
THEY'RE GOING TO BLAME PUTIN,
TRUMP, OPEC, THE PANDEMIC, OR
PRETEND INFLATION IS A GOOD
THING.
ALL OF THE ABOVE BUT WE KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL TAKE ZERO
RESPONSIBILITY.
THIS IS THEIR BAD ECONOMIC
POLICY, BAD ENERGY POLICY
CAUSING ALL OF THIS.
BUT ACCORDING TO THEM EVERY BAD
THING THAT HAPPENS IS TOTALLY
COMPLETE LAYOUT OF THEIR CONTROL
EVEN THOUGH THEY WERE THE ONES
THAT SUPPRESSED AMERICA'S OIL
AND GAS CAPABILITIES.
THEY ARTIFICIALLY REDUCE THE
WORLD SUPPLY.
LO AND BEHOLD YOU ARE PAYING
RECORD PRICES AND PAY MORE FOR
EVERY ITEM YOU BUY IN EVERY
STORE YOU GO TO.
BY THE WAY, THEY ALSO PRINTED AN
OBSCENE AMOUNT OF MONEY DURING
JOE BIDEN'S FIRST YEAR IN
OFFICE.
NOW WITH CHINA'S MAJOR TRADING
HUB WATCHING WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
SHANGHAI, NOT A LOT OF PEOPLE
TALKING ABOUT IT.
THEY ARE FACING A DYSTOPIAN
LOCKED DOWN AMID NEW OMICRON
SURGE, OR MICRON 2.0 AS WE ARE
CALLING IT.
BA.2.
AS THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY REFERS
TO IT.
THE SUPPLY CHAIN WILL BE PUSHED
TO ANYTHING WE'VE EVER WITNESSED
AND RIGHT NOW IT'S PRETTY BAD
BECAUSE THIS COUNTRY IMPORTS
MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF PHONES AND
COMPUTERS AND CHIPS AND OTHER
ELECTRONICS FROM CHINA.
SO YOU CAN EXPECT THOSE COSTS
WOULD SHOOT THROUGH THE ROOF IF
YOU CAN EVEN GET THEM.
AS PER USUAL, BIDEN IS NOT
PREPARED FOR ANY OF THIS.
THERE IS NO PLAN B FOR THIS
ADMINISTRATION TO BRING DOWN
PRICES, CURB INFLATION, OR EASE
THE PAIN OF THE PUMP.
THEY ARE TELLING YOU TO GO OUT
AND BUY ELECTRIC CAR OR UNTIL WE
GET CLEANER RENEWABLE ENERGY,
YOU'RE JUST GOING TO HAVE TO PAY
THE FREIGHT OF HIGH GAS PRICES.
THEY KEEP SAYING IT AND LAUGHING
ABOUT IT AND BLAMING EVERYONE
BUT THEMSELVES.
AS A RESULT, BIDEN'S APPROVAL
NUMBERS CONTINUE TO PLUMMET.
A NEW "CBS NEWS" POLL HAS THEIR
LOWEST NUMBER FOR JOE BIDEN.
JOE IS UNDERWATER ON ALMOST
EVERY SINGLE MAJOR ISSUE.
LOOK AT THIS.
61% OF AMERICANS DISAPPROVE OF
HIS HANDLING ON CRIME.
62% DISAPPROVE HIS POLICIES ON
IMMIGRATION.
THAT WOULD BE THE BOARD OR
DISASTER.
63% DISAPPROVE HIS HANDLING OF
THE ECONOMY.
69% NO JOE CAUSED INFLATION.
MEANWHILE, 55% ALSO DISAPPROVE
OF JOE'S HANDLING OF UKRAINE AND
FOR GOOD REASON.
THE IMAGES FROM PUTIN'S
INVASION, THEY ARE HORRIFIC.
IT IS EVIL IN OUR TIME.
THOUSANDS OF INNOCENT CIVILIANS
HAVE BEEN SLAUGHTERED.
OTHERS TORTURED, MILLIONS
DISPLACED.
ENTIRE TOWNS AND CITIES AND
VILLAGES HAVE BEEN LEVELED.
CITIES REDUCED TO RUBBLE.
WE ARE WITNESSING A HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS ON A SCALE NOT SEEN SINCE
WORLD WAR II AND YET WHERE IS
THE URGENCY FROM JOE BIDEN?
OVER THE WEEKEND DURING AN
INTERVIEW ON "60 MINUTES,"
PROBABLY THE BEST SEGMENT, I
WILL SAY THIS, THAT THEY ARE
PROBABLY DONE IN 15 YEARS.
THAT'S THE INTERVIEW WITH SCOTT
AND PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY.
ZELENSKYY HELD NOTHING BACK,
CALLING OUT NATO, THE U.N.
SECURITY COUNCIL.
WHAT GOOD IS THE SECURITY
COUNCIL IF YOU DON'T PROVIDE
SECURITY?
AND JOE BIDEN.
ALSO THE U.N. DRAGGING THEIR
FEET IN THE FACE OF NOTHING BUT
PURE EVIL.
WATCH THIS.
>> SPEAKING TO NATO, YOU CALLED
THEM WEAK.
SPEAKING TO THE U.N. SECURITY
COUNCIL YOU SAID IF YOU CAN'T
HELP, YOU SHOULDN'T EXIST.
NOT VERY DIPLOMATIC OF YOU.
I WONDER WHY YOU FEEL THE NEED
TO SPEAK SO BLUNTLY.
>> WHEN YOU'RE WORKING AT
DIPLOMACY, THERE ARE NO RESULTS.
ALL OF THIS IS VERY
BUREAUCRATIC.
THAT'S WHY THE WAY I AM TALKING
TO THEM IS ABSOLUTELY JUSTIFIED.
I REMEMBER, ALL OF US REMEMBER
BOOKS ABOUT THE SECOND WORLD WAR
AND ABOUT THE DEVIL IN UNIFORM.
ADOLF HITLER.
ARE THOSE COUNTRIES WHO DID NOT
PARTICIPATE IN THE WAR
RESPONSIBLE?
THE COUNTRIES WHO LET GERMAN
FORCES MARCH THROUGHOUT EUROPE.
DOES THE WORLD CARRY
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE GENOCIDE?
YES.
YES, IT DOES.
>> WHAT ARE YOU ASKING OF
PRESIDENT BIDEN?
>> TO TELL YOU THE TRUTH, LONG
AGO I ASKED PRESIDENT BIDEN FOR
VERY SPECIFIC ITEMS.
HE HAS THE LIST.
>> Sean: AS I HAVE SAID, BIDEN
CANNOT PUT U.S. BOOTS ON THE
GROUND.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY IS NOT
ASKING FOR THAT.
THE ONLY DISAGREEMENT I MIGHT
HAVE WITH HIM IS ON THE NO-FLY
ZONE ISSUE.
WE CAN GET UKRAINE.
BY THE WAY, NATO COUNTRIES OUGHT
TO BE STEPPING UP THE URGENCY.
SO SHOULD JOE BIDEN.
SO SHOULD ALL OF WESTERN EUROPE.
HE'S ASKING FOR THE WEAPONS SO
THAT THE UKRAINIANS CAN DEFEND
FREEDOM IN THEIR OWN LAND.
THEY ARE NOT ASKING FOR BOOTS ON
THE GROUND.
THEY NEED THE WEAPONS.
THEY NEED THE AMMO.
THEY NEEDED YESTERDAY SO THEY
CAN DRIVE RUSSIA OUT OF THEIR
COUNTRY AND THEY ARE WILLING TO
DO THE FIGHTING THEMSELVES.
WE NEED TO DO IT AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT BIDEN, NATO,
WESTERN EUROPE, THEY HAVE NOT
SHOWN THE NECESSARY URGENCY FOR
THIS MOMENT IN HISTORY.
OVER THE WEEKEND, BRITISH MY
MINISTER BORIS JOHNSON, HE DID
MAKE A SURPRISE TRIP TO KYIV TO
SUPPORT ZELENSKYY.
GOT TO GIVE THEM A LOT OF
CREDIT.
DON'T EXPECT A SIMILAR TRIP FROM
YOUR PRESIDENT, JOE BIDEN.
ACCORDING TO JOE, THEY WON'T LET
HIM GO.
I'M NOT ALLOWED TO TAKE
QUESTIONS OR ANYTHING.
THEY GET MAD AT ME WHEN I GO
BACK AND THE OTHER ROOM.
YOU ARE THE PRESIDENT.
YOU WANT TO GO TO KYIV, GO TO
KYIV.
TODAY OUR OWN JACQUI HEINRICH
ASKED JUST WHO THEY ARE.
THIS IS INTERESTING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HAS THE PRESIDENT ASKED TO
TO GOTO UKRAINE.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO GET INTO
PRIVATE CONVERSATIONS.
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS WE ARE
NOT PLANNING A TRIP BY THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
TO UKRAINE.
WHAT IS MOST IMPORTANT TO
UKRAINIAN LEADERSHIP IS THAT WE
ARE EXPEDITING WEAPONS AND
GETTING THE MEAN THE ASSISTANCE
AND SECURITY ASSISTANCE THEY
NEED AND THAT'S WHAT OUR FOCUS
IS ON.
>> IF THE PRESIDENT -- WHO
DECIDES IF THE PRESIDENT GOES TO
UKRAINE OR NOT?
HE SAID HE EXPRESSED INTEREST IN
GOING TO UKRAINE BUT "THEY
WOULDN'T LET ME."
>> I'M NOT GOING TO GET INTO
PRIVATE CONSIDERATIONS
INTERNALLY ON THAT FRONT.
>> Sean: THEY WON'T LET ME?
REALLY, JOE?
MAY BE NOBODY TOLD YOU BUT
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO BE THE
PRESIDENT.
IN OTHER WORDS, JOE IS TO BUSY
GETTING REST HE DOESN'T HAVE
TIME FOR INTERNATIONAL TRAVEL.
GOOD FOR BORIS JOHNSON.
UNFORTUNATELY JOE DOESN'T HAVE
THE URGENCY, ANY URGENCY
WHATSOEVER WHEN IT COMES TO ANY
MAJOR ISSUE.
TODAY HE SHOUTED, SQUINTING,
LIED A LOT.
HE DID IT IN THIS SPEECH ABOUT
GHOST GUNS ON THE EVILS OF
AMERICAN GUN OWNERSHIP DURING
YET ANOTHER BIZARRE SET OF
REMARKS.
THE HITS KEEP ON COMING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE COP KNOWS BY FIRST NAME
WHO OWNS THE CORNER DRUGSTORE,
WHO LIVES IN THE APARTMENT ABOV.
THE PASTORS OF THE CHURCHES.
RIGHT NOW YOU GET OUT OF PRISON
AFTER SERVING TIME YOU GET A BUS
TICKET IN 25 BUCKS AND YOU GO TO
THE SAME BRIDGE THAT YOU LEFT
TWO, FIVE, TEN YEARS EARLIER.
THINK ABOUT THE MASS SHOOTINGS.
AS MANY AS 100 ROUNDS.
IT'S A WEAPON OF WAR.
PROUD TO NOMINATE STEVE
DETTELBACH.
SORRY I MISPRONOUNCED HER NAME.
>> Sean: NOT GREAT.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, BIDEN'S WAR ON
GUNS BEGINS AND ENDS WITH
LAW-ABIDING AMERICANS IF HE IS
DO NOTHING TO STOP THE SMUGGLING
OF WEAPONS AND DRUGS ACROSS THE
WIDE OPEN SOUTHERN BORDER.
HE'S DOING NOTHING TO PREVENT
CRIME.
GUESS WHAT.
YOU CAN'T PURSUE HAPPINESS IF
YOU DON'T HAVE LAW AND ORDER AND
SAFETY AND SECURITY IN YOUR TOWN
OR YOUR CITY OR WHERE YOU LIVE.
IF YOU DON'T LOCK UP VIOLENT
OFFENDERS AND YOU HAVE NO BAIL
LAWS, DEFUND THE COPS, GUESS
WHAT.
THAT'S WHY CRIME IS SURGING ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY.
INSTEAD HE WANTS TO LIMIT LAWFUL
AMERICANS AND THEIR ABILITY TO
MAKE THEIR OWN WEAPONS, MOVE
THAT'S CLEARLY, OBVIOUSLY
TRANSPARENTLY UNCONSTITUTIONAL
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS.
OF COURSE THE RULE OF LAW MEANS
NOTHING TO JOE ALSO.
WE DO HAVE COEQUAL BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT.
BY THE WAY THAT WOULD BE UP TO
THE LEGISLATIVE BRANCH TO BRINGG
INTO LOT LEFT THE PRESIDENT
SIGNED IT IF HE WANTS TO DO IT.
AND I MEAN IT BRING YOU THE